[Music]
valerie is in chicago hi
valerie welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call today
sure what's up so um
all right i'm 24. i am almost going to
be 25
in two months i make 60 thousand dollars
a year at a job
i completely 100 percent hate
um i have no savings i was paycheck to
paycheck
and i have several addictions that hold
me back
and cause me to take out cash advances
to the point where
i am a thousand dollars in the hole
every time my direct deposit hit
um i've been a chronic marijuana smoker
for oh
like seven years now and i have been
basically
eating straight up ubereats and
doordash for like every meal i mean i
haven't cooked a meal
you smoke a lot of pot and you're hungry
all the time who knew
oh my god only on the day
like something happens between the
hunger pang and the like i just black
out and then there's a transaction and
someone's at my door and it just happens
every time
and i just can't i can't seem to get a
handle
of of just i don't know discipline and i
want to grow up so bad
and yet i want a certain life for myself
and i just feel like i'm constantly
carrying around all of this like shame
and guilt because i just can't seem to
get it together and i know what i have
to do but i just don't know how to start
valerie um before we talk about you know
this i have one quick question because
you're saying you're in a whole a
thousand dollars a month
what what kind of debt do you have
payday lender you said
well okay so i have general debt like i
have a car repossession and stuff like
that and a couple medical
the debts that are like ten thousand
but um i when i say a thousand dollars
in the hole i mean
i have like 10 applications installed on
my phone where i can get a cash advance
like instantly
right and so i literally go one by one
down the list
and i just do whatever i need to do to
get the next you know
bag of eater meal or whatever here's the
thing i want to say
and then i and we know you know dave is
going to chime into as well but
i want to i want to commend you for at
least admitting
the first step to anything to moving
forward is admitting and acknowledging
the fact that you have a problem
and you you came on the show and you
said that uh
the second part of that is though uh
dave and i
can't give you discipline you can only
give yourself discipline
and as i listen to you one of the key
things that that i hear
we can give you the practical steps on
how to get out of the situation that
you're in
but it's so much deeper than just that
there's so much it sounds like you don't
have a reason deep down inside of
yourself
to why you need to stop and why you need
to make a decision
so you keep going back and back and back
into it because there's there's nothing
deep down saying stop
there's no reason why that when you feel
like getting another bag of weed when
you feel like getting
uh some more food when you feel like
going and doing this nothing can
stop you deep down and so i wanted i
want to encourage you not giving nothing
practical today
i want to encourage you to spend some
time today to really sit down
and ask yourself why why do i want to
give up smoking why do i want to give up
this
and ask yourself that five times and by
the time you get to the fifth answer you
should be in tears
you should be emotional that why should
make you cry
and that why will push you through the
price and commitment
of what it's going to take to stop
smoking to stop living a life of not
having discipline
and that's one thing that i would
encourage you i never had a smoking
problem
but i did have the eating problem i did
have the chasing ladies problem
you know and i had to really develop a
wise so you know what i'm tired of
living this life
and i'm tired of leaving this life
because i want more for my kids want
more for my future
and that why push me through of saying
no
okay so i really wanna hear you you know
i mean
and i want to say so much more about
that the only time people change
on anything whether it's um you know eat
a bag of oreos
um whether it is um any any
just pick a destructive habit that we
all have destructive habits
or destructive tendencies the only
reason we ever stop
doing them is when the pain of where we
are the disgust
with the person in the mirror becomes so
great
that that pain is greater than the pain
of change because changing is always
painful agreed
yeah it's very painful yeah not doing
things the way you've done them
and radically uh detoxing your body
getting on an exercise program eating
healthy
uh obviously stopping the drugs uh
all of those things are are you know
doing anything that's
different than the way you've been doing
it even if the way you're doing it's
destructive
is is painful to change and only when
the pain of same
the pain of where we are is great enough
and it doesn't have to be a
it doesn't have to be an external pain
it doesn't have to be the doctor says if
you don't stop this you're going to die
now that would be an example when we go
okay i'll stop it right
i don't want to die but it can just be
what i heard
in your voice as you were describing
this was
um when you're in this
uh uh this loop you don't like you
you don't you don't respect you don't
respect yourself
i'm not i i mean you just you know what
i'm saying i mean like you
if you were it's almost like you were
outside of yourself looking in and go
you know this chick smokes weed and
orders you know orders everything in
sight
has no money and it's in a chaotic life
i don't know who this woman is
and you're looking like you're looking
in from the outside and i heard that
kind of disgust in your voice
didn't i it's there for sure
and i'm not trying to shame you i'm
saying that can actually be a building
block
and you go you know what yeah i'm sick
and tired of being sick and tired
les brown the great motivator and you
can look him up on youtube he's fun to
watch
um says people change their lives when
they finally say
that's it i've had it and
anthony's right i can't do that for you
i can just believe in you that when you
do that
you're going to see a tremendous change
but it does come i like it i like his
suggestion best of all
we need to have what is a really good
reason
for you to break this cycle
to be honest i watch a lot of videos
about entrepreneurship
but i know that if i can't even handle
my food bill i can't handle capital or
people
okay there we go yeah i like that i want
to start my own business
and until i get my crap together i'm not
going to be able to do anything at that
but fail
that's what you just said right that's
exactly what i said
yeah and so there's a good why yeah
i'm gonna clean up my crap here
so to clean up my life so i can start my
own business and be a successful
entrepreneur
because i want that more
than i want to sit and watch netflix
reruns and order uber eats and smoke a
joint yep
and then ask yourself why do you want
that business yeah why is it why is it
you want to run your own business that's
a good question
i think that i hate your job i work
i work in like healthcare like finance
and
i feel like a cog in the machine
i've wanted something more meaningful
for a long time yeah i want to do
something where i can actually help
people and do something that matters
yeah did you just say that that's
exactly what i said that's a good why
that is a that's a good reason to
straighten up your crap girl
i like you you're awesome call us back
tell us how you're doing okay
hold on we're gonna put you into ramsey
plus and help you with the money stuff
but you won't fix that till you fix the
other stuff either but we're gonna help
you anyway
hey call us back and let us know how
you're doing this is the dave ramsey
show